all of the pre-order details for
hogwarts legacy have been released they
are made official
and it's really really confusing guys
needlessly so i might add but it's all
good i'm here i'm gonna break it down
for you and we're gonna try and figure
out which version is the best version
for you but this is honestly so
complicated guys i don't really know why
they made it this way we're going to go
through it here we're going to go
through it step by step look at
everything that's been confirmed and
then hopefully at the end of this video
you're going to have a much better idea
of which version you want to buy okay so
let's start very simple there is the
standard edition of the game which is
what you see here this is available for
pre-order on amazon best buy gamestop
all the usual places at the time of me
recording this video it is not up yet on
xbox playstation or places like steam
and epic game store for a digital
pre-order i assume that will be
happening in very short order the
pricing breakdown we can see right here
it's going to be 59.99 for the nintendo
switch we still do not have a release
date for that one for the playstation 4
you're also looking at 59.99 we'll
release on february 10th playstation 5
version will be 69.99 also releasing on
february 10th xbox one version 59.99
february 10th and then the xbox series s
and x version 69.99 also releasing
february 10th okay that is the easy part
right there also the pc version i would
assume is going to be 59.99 again we
don't have official confirmation of that
but based on what we've seen of other
games i expect that to be the case most
new pc games have not yet hit that 69.99
mark like they have on console all right
guys literally as i was editing this
video we got another clarification
specifically on the hippogriff mount so
i had put out this tweet here first look
here at the onyx hippogriff mount which
is available by pre-order either the
deluxe or collector's edition because
that is what it leads you to believe
right here pre-order bonus right here in
the fine print pre-order the deluxe or
collector's editions and get the onyx
hippogriff mount that is what it says in
both of these right here however
community manager chandler wood this is
official right here
he comments to on my post and says the
onyx hippogriff mount is available for
any pre-order edition including the
standard so this is a big
i think a big point here for people who
really like this onyx hippogriff you do
not have to pre-order uh the deluxe
edition or the digital deluxe edition
despite what it says right here that is
not the case you can actually get the
onyx hippogriff as a pre-order bonus of
the standard edition as well so thank
you chandler for providing that
additional clarification there okay now
is where things start to get confusing
because we have the newly announced
deluxe edition so i want to be very
clear here this is the physical copy of
the deluxe edition because it's kind of
crazy but it is actually different if
you get the digital deluxe edition all
right so the hogwarts legacy deluxe
edition will include the thestral mount
chandler wood community manager has
confirmed this is the only way to get
the thestral mount you're not going to
be able to unlock it in game if you want
to be able to ride on thestrals you have
to purchase it as part of the deluxe or
the collector's edition which we'll get
to that one here in a second of course
it will include the full game here you
also get a different box art for the
deluxe edition i really like what
they've done with this box art here then
you're gonna get the dark arts cosmetic
set which includes the dark arts battle
arena as well as 72 hours early access
for the game and then last but not least
we have the onyx hippogriff mount here
which looks to be just a standard
hippogriff but with a black coloring
instead i think it looks really nice and
so that is everything you get with the
deluxe edition of the game now i know
what you're wondering what about pc well
there is not a deluxe edition version of
the pc that i have been able to find
instead you would have to go with the
digital deluxe edition and so here we
flip over to the digital deluxe edition
and you'll notice that most everything
is the same however there are a few
differences and they are right here at
the bottom under this also includes so
right here we have the also includes
dark arts battle arena so that's the
same as the other one 72 hours early
access that's the same
but you will also get the dark arts
garrison hat
asterisk right here we're going to talk
about that in a second and then this is
the big one a cross gin upgrade so my
friends what this means if you are
planning to get the ps5 or xbox series x
digital versions from what i can read
right here and i'll be sure to update
you all if any of this changes but from
what i can read right here there is no
reason for you to buy the digital
version of ps5 or xbox series x there's
just no reason because you're going to
get the cross gen upgrade again this is
digital deluxe only not the deluxe
edition the digital deluxe edition which
is different everything else though
still the same destro mount full game
dark arts cosmetic onyx hippogriff and
so on and then the asterisk right here
they also want to make sure that you
know this is only available in the
hogwarts legacy digital deluxe edition
so again this dark arts garrison hat
even if you buy the regular deluxe
edition of the game again this is not
the digital one here the regular deluxe
you will not get the garrison hat now
you might be wondering what about the
switch well the switch was shown in the
trailer as having a deluxe edition and
also with the tagline underneath
available in stores and digitally so
switch owners if you want the deluxe
edition looks like you'll be able to
purchase it digitally or physically no
worries there pc your only option is
going to be digital now in terms of
pricing it is expected that the digital
deluxe edition will retail for eighty
dollars the thing we don't know just yet
is how much that will cost across the
ps4 the ps5 the switch you would expect
that you'll see those ten dollar price
differences based on whether you're
buying current gen or last gen in terms
of pricing i will make sure to pin a
comment below so it breaks it all down
for you and also include a couple
affiliate links as well which helps out
the channel and no extra cost to you if
you want to purchase through that
totally up to you but my guess right now
is that it's 80 for the digital deluxe
basically subtract ten dollars if you're
looking at the last gen version or the
pc version
okay deep breath guys we're going in
even more here this right here is the
officially confirmed hogwarts legacy
collectors edition and we have steel
case plus the full game chandler wood
confirmed on twitter for the console
versions you will get a hard copy of the
game now one thing i am still a little
confused about is that it says steel
case and full game and then it has a
picture of the deluxe game box back here
well chandler actually did an unboxing
and it did not include this other
physical game box now sometimes you can
see differences in territory there based
on whether you're in the us uk or
another country i actually saw this with
the metroid dread collectors edition the
us only came with the steel book whereas
other territories actually included the
steelbook and the regular box so i'm
assuming that chandler unboxed the us
version maybe we can get some
clarification on that but i would expect
that you're only going to get the steel
case and not this game box right here
now for the pc folks you will still get
the steel case but you will also get a
digital download code for the game as
far as the digital goodies go you get
the dark arts pack again dark arts
cosmetic destro mount dark arts battle
arena and this one does also include the
dark arts garrison hat the 72 hours
early access and a digital item
exclusive to this version collector's
edition only the kelpie robe which they
showed off in a very brief shot during
chandler's unboxing video then for kind
of the core centerpiece of all of this
you have the floating wand life size
they add with the book base this book is
going to need to be plugged into the
wall to get this little floating effect
here it is expected to be 299
for ps5 xbox series x and then 289 for
pc and the last gen versions at the time
of recording this it is actually
unconfirmed if the switch version will
have a collector's edition or not now to
be completely honest with you guys here
i think 300 is way
way too much for this you don't get an
art book you don't even get the
soundtrack they're essentially charging
you 220
dollars for a kelpie robe the steel case
and then the floating wand piece now to
be fair it's hard to say the exact
quality of this thing just from looking
at a video i'll say that from watching
chandler's unboxing video i was kind of
disappointed even more i didn't think it
looked as high quality as i was hoping
but i want to hear what you guys think
which version will you be purchasing let
me know in the comments thank you all so
much for watching and i'll talk to you
again soon